A BIG REASON FOR THAT, FIVE
GOAL, FIVE ASSISTS IN THAT IS A.
A NEW BEHIND THE SCENEH OFF FOR
ANDREW COPP.
POOLMAN GAINING CENTRE. IT
HE WRISTS THAT PUCK INTO THE
AND NOW STRIPPED OF IT BY
EKMAN-LARSSON WHO PASSES THAT
ONE AHEAD TO HORVAT.G,
DROPPING IT OFF.
WHEELER, WIDE. TO CENTRE IT.
FA.
HIS WRISTER, SCORES! AROUND WELH
SO THAT EKMAN-LARSSON HAST, SENG
THAT PUCK OFF OF THE FAR IT.
MIGHT HAVE CAUGHT A PIECE OF THE
OFFICIAL RIGHT THERE.
LAMMIKKO IS GOING FOR THET IS
HUGHES NOW, NEARSIDE.
AROUND.
OUTSIDE THE LINE TO CENTRE.
YEAR AND FIVE OF THOSE COMING IN
BUT, STILL, THAT IS A
HEALTHY PERCENTAGE OF GOALS IN
CANUCKS GOAL,
DEMKO NOW, SENDING IT AROUND AND
PIONK, WAITS, INTO BURROUGHS, AE
SCORES! IT HIT THE HIS FIRST
AND LAST NIGHT IT WAS A WRISTERD
ABLE TO BLOCK THAT PASS AND
LEAVING ELIAS PETTERSSON
FRUSTRATED AND SKATES
OF CHAISSON BUT MILLER, HE GETS
TO THAT PUCK AND N
CONTROL, YOU HAVE TO FLOOD IT.
LOOK AT THE JETS ON
FINDING MILLER.ncer: FROM HELP E
STREAK AND RIGHT
BACK ON THE H H
YOUR KIDS FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FROM PR.
THIS IS MORRISSEY, WATCHED NOW
.
NIKOLAJ EHLERS AND